Probably my boldest prediction is that people will stop treating these models as unintelligent. All these different features that we are adding on to LLMs. First it was reg, retrieval augmentation, then it was memories. You know, that's what they're kind of currently working on. On top of that is like context compression, which you could argue is a form of synthesizing information. You're just describing the process of like, design. designing intelligence. Just because a plane doesn't fly like a bird doesn't mean it can't fly.
我最大胆的预测是，人们将不再把这些模型视为缺乏智能。我们正在为大语言模型（LLM）添加各种不同的功能。起初是 RAG（检索增强生成），然后是记忆功能。你知道，这正是他们目前正在研究的方向。在此之上还有上下文压缩，你可以认为这是一种信息合成的形式。你其实就是在描述设计智能的过程。就像飞机飞行的方式与鸟类不同，但这并不意味着它不能飞行。
Yeah. We are building intelligence systems. We have put intelligence in a bottle and we are adding intelligence features to these models. We should have had a global holiday for passing the Turing test. And it's just, yeah, anyways, as my wife tells me, I have, like, radical views on all these topics. And most people, you know, she says, she tells me that my views are outside the Overton window. And welcome to ADSP. the podcast episode 270 recorded on January 13th,
是的。我们正在构建智能系统。我们将智能装进了瓶子，并正在为这些模型添加智能特性。我们本该为通过图灵测试设立一个全球性的节日。总之，正如我妻子告诉我的，我对所有这些话题都有激进的观点。她说我的观点超出了奥弗顿之窗（Overton window）。欢迎来到 ADSP，这是第 270 期播客，录制于 1 月 13 日，
20206. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host, Bryce, we make our 2026 predictions, talk about the future, AI, books, and more. 2025, it's in the rear view, mere. 26 is here. It is January 13th as we record this.
2026 年。我是 Connor。今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，做出我们对 2026 年的预测，谈论未来、人工智能、书籍等等。2025 年已经成为过去，2026 年已经到来。我们录制节目的时间是 1 月 13 日。
What do we want to say? I mean, one of my favorite episodes of all time, I believe is episode 11, I think it is. And it was the. Star Wars introed episode where I used the Star Wars theme. I believe, was it episode 111? Yes. C++, 23 ranges, 22 retro and Star Wars. So it was, I guess, it was three years ago when we were doing the 2022 retro. And you started talking about how 2023 was going to be the year that the Empire strikes back.
我们想说什么呢？我的意思是，我最喜欢的节目之一，我认为是第 11 期，还是第 111 期？就是那个我用了《星球大战》主题曲的《星球大战》开场集。是的，C++ 23 ranges、22 年回顾和《星球大战》。所以我想，那是三年前我们做 2022 年回顾的时候。你当时开始谈论 2023 年将是“帝国反击战”的一年。
So do you have any more great analogies? They can be Star Wars themed again. I mean, and or came out. Obviously, everyone agrees. It's one of the best shows of all time. What's in store for 2026? Is it the AI bubble popping? Which obviously it's not going to pop, folks.
所以你还有什么很棒的类比吗？它们可以再次以《星球大战》为主题。我的意思是，《安多》（Andor）出来了，显然大家都同意它是史上最好的剧集之一。2026 年会有什么？是人工智能泡沫破裂吗？显然它不会破裂，各位。
It was just a wobble. It was just a wobble. I've been listening to the Acquired podcast a lot. And they, in more recent episodes, they've started at the start by saying, this is not investment advice. They put a little disclaimer at the start. to their podcast. Maybe we need that.
那只是一个小波动。那只是一个小波动。我一直在听《Acquired》播客。在最近的几期节目中，他们开头都会说，这不是投资建议。他们在播客开头加了一个小免责声明。也许我们也需要那样做。
I'm going to speculate. I'm going to make some very specific speculations about some specific people and what they may do. Are we going to name these people? Yeah, of course, I'm going to name these people. So first of all, first of all, I will speculate that sometime either this year or next year that you, Connor, are going to get nerd sniped into like ML kernel design. And I think at some point, what I've hinted at on past episodes, that at some point, we're going to be like, all right, we should go train our own language model and figure out how to do that.
我要进行推测。我要对某些特定的人以及他们可能做的事情做出一些非常具体的推测。我们要点名吗？是的，当然，我要点名。首先，我推测今年或明年，你，Connor，会被“书呆子狙击”（nerd sniped）去研究机器学习内核设计。我想在某个时候，正如我在过去节目中暗示的那样，我们会说，好吧，我们应该去训练我们自己的语言模型，并弄清楚如何做到这一点。
At some point the next two years, I think that'll happen. Because I think at some point, you're going to get nerds typed by this. And I say that having somewhat been nerds typed by this now myself, and there's all sorts of cool algorithms underneath these ML models. models. And it's like a place where you can really spend a lot of time and effort finding the perfect algorithm. And there is a great value in return on investment for that. So I think that'll happen to you. Well, I have the power to make you wrong. But anyways, in this case, I don't, I don't think so. I don't think so. Time will tell. My second, my second prediction is that I think we will have Sean Baxter back on this podcast sometime in the next year or two.
在未来两年的某个时候，我认为这会发生。因为我觉得你迟早会被这个吸引。我这么说是因为我自己也曾被它吸引过，这些机器学习模型底层有各种很酷的算法。这是一个你可以真正投入大量时间和精力去寻找完美算法的地方。而且这方面的投资回报率很高。所以我认为这会发生在你身上。好吧，我有能力让你预测错误。但无论如何，在这种情况下，我不这么认为。我不这么认为。时间会证明一切。我的第二个预测是，我认为明年或后年我们会在这个播客上再次请到 Sean Baxter。
All right. So you started off with one where you gave me the power to, you know, have you be wrong. And technically you've done the same thing again, but also you have more ability to make that one come true. But I could just be like, that's it. We're not having Sean on. Playing with fire here. There's reason. I mean, you're not even exploring the interesting part of that, which is like,
好吧。所以你开始时给我的权力是，你知道，让你预测错误。从技术上讲，你又做了同样的事情，但你也有更大的能力让那个预测成真。但我可以直接说，就这样吧，我们不请 Sean 了。你在玩火。这里有原因。我的意思是，你甚至没有探讨其中有趣的部分，那就是，
Why would Bryce want to have Sean back on the podcast? I mean, obviously, Sean is the best person to talk to. Some of his conversations we have with him were like our best episodes ever. That one that was like Circle versus C++ versus whatever. Yes, but is that, but you should ask yourself, why is it that Bryce thinks that we're going to have Sean back on this podcast? I mean, we work for the same company. I know why. I don't think you do because the thing, the thing is very, very recent.
为什么 Bryce 想让 Sean 回到播客？我的意思是，显然，Sean 是最适合交谈的人。我们和他进行的一些对话是我们有史以来最好的节目。就是那期关于 Circle 对比 C++ 对比其他什么的。是的，但你应该问问自己，为什么 Bryce 认为我们会请 Sean 回到这个播客？我的意思是，我们在同一家公司工作。我知道原因。我不认为你知道，因为那件事非常、非常新。
It's very, very recent. Okay, maybe I don't know. Maybe I don't know. Yes. I think Sean is working on some very exciting things. And as soon as they are things that he can talk about, I'm going to say, Sean should come back onto the podcast. So those are my two predictions.
非常、非常新。好吧，也许我不知道。也许我不知道。是的。我认为 Sean 正在研究一些非常令人兴奋的事情。一旦这些事情是他可以谈论的，我会说，Sean 应该回到播客上来。所以这就是我的两个预测。
Bigger, like macro world predictions, I think we'll see a lot more. more AI in the workplace the next year, like companies trying to produce the sort of results with AI that we've seen for coating. They'll try to take that to other white-collar jobs, and we'll see more like tools and frameworks built out around that. We'll see a lot more adoption of that. And I think that there will be a lot more talk about edge AI and robots and automation and AI and our various devices. I think we'll see a lot of that. And I think it's a great time to be a staff software engineer,
更宏观的世界预测，我认为明年我们会看到更多的人工智能进入工作场所，就像公司试图用人工智能产生我们在编程方面看到的那种结果。他们会尝试将其应用到其他白领工作中，我们会看到更多围绕此构建的工具和框架。我们会看到更多的采用。而且我认为会有更多关于边缘人工智能、机器人、自动化以及我们各种设备中的人工智能的讨论。我想我们会看到很多这样的情况。而且我认为现在是成为一名资深软件工程师的好时机，
and it is an awful time to be anybody more junior than that. I think there's an increase. Somebody just asked me today about their programming in like Java and some other languages and they're asking, like, what recommendations would you have for me if I want to get into lower level languages, C++, et cetera, if I want to get more systems software? And what I told him is, and he asked, oh, should I learn, like, modern best practices and like the APIs and, like, good design philosophy? And it was like, no, don't do any of that. Learn performance analysis and optimization, how to benchmark things, and how to reason about hardware and performance,
但对于任何比这更初级的人来说，现在是一个糟糕的时期。我认为有一个增长。今天有人问我关于他们使用 Java 和其他语言编程的问题，他们问，如果我想进入底层语言，比如 C++ 等，如果我想做更多的系统软件，你有什么建议？我告诉他的是，他问，哦，我应该学习现代最佳实践、API 和好的设计哲学吗？我说，不，不要做那些。学习性能分析和优化，如何进行基准测试，以及如何思考硬件和性能，
debugging, et cetera, I think those are skills that are still very valuable in an era where we can have AI automate a lot of the laborious sort of authoring of the code. Obviously, being able to design the system is still an important skill. But I think that there's a lot of people who have those design skills. I think a far more in demand skill is being able to reason about performance and optimize codes and then also debug codes. So I think those will be increasingly important skills. Everything lower than staff engineer, though, really? That's the threshold?
调试等等，我认为这些技能在我们可以利用人工智能自动化大量繁琐的代码编写工作的时代仍然非常有价值。显然，能够设计系统仍然是一项重要的技能。但我认为有很多人拥有这些设计技能。我认为需求量更大的技能是能够思考性能、优化代码以及调试代码。所以我认为这些将是越来越重要的技能。不过，所有低于资深工程师的职位真的都这样吗？那是门槛吗？
Yeah, I think so. I think that companies that are hiring are only hiring, you know, to very top, very senior people or people who are, you know, I imagine there will be. be like more product manageries sort of roles in the future because it's a lot easier for people it's a lot easier for like a person to be like a one a one stop shop for a whole like product or feature because they can be the person who like meets with the customers figures out what the product should be goes and builds the product using AI and and then you know brings it to market does the outreach, does the marketing, et cetera.
是的，我想是这样。我认为招聘的公司只招聘非常顶尖、非常资深的人，或者那些，你知道，我想未来会有更多产品经理类的角色，因为一个人成为整个产品或功能的一站式服务商要容易得多，因为他们可以成为那个与客户会面、弄清楚产品应该是什么、使用人工智能去构建产品，然后将其推向市场、进行推广、营销等等的人。
I think we'll see a lot more sort of integration of multiple different parts of software development and software publication into a couple, into fewer people. I think people's roles will get more general because there will be less of a demand for people whose specialty is just outputting code manually themselves. So people who have diverse skill sets
我认为我们会看到更多软件开发和软件发布的不同部分整合到少数人身上。我认为人们的角色会变得更加通用，因为对那些专门手动输出代码的人的需求会减少。所以拥有多样化技能的人
are going to benefit. Or people who have very, very deep skill sets, but in a very specific way, like people who are, you know, leaders in their fields of like mathematics or, you know, performance optimization or something like more domain specific. But just, you know, being a junior software engineer right now,
将会受益。或者那些拥有非常、非常深厚技能，但以非常具体方式的人，比如那些在数学、性能优化等领域处于领先地位的人，或者更特定于领域的人。但仅仅是作为一个初级软件工程师，
I think it's bad time for that. Do you think that's going to change at any point, or is this the way it is, a new paradigm shift. There's a paradigm shift and this is just the world we live in now. I think that yes, I think it will change because if you believe that we're in the midst of an industrial revolution, then in the future there will be a lot more things that are like powered under the hood by software. And so eventually the AI revolution will mean that there is a lot more demand for software in general.
我认为现在是个糟糕的时机。你认为这种情况会在某个时候改变，还是这就是现状，一种新的范式转移？这是一个范式转移，这就是我们现在生活的世界。我认为是的，我认为它会改变，因为如果你相信我们正处于工业革命之中，那么未来会有更多由软件驱动的东西。所以最终，人工智能革命将意味着对软件的需求总体上会增加。
And so, like, every time there's been increases in efficiency and, like, worker efficiency, we've seen, like, demand increased, too, because the cost of the thing goes down. So I think we'll see that happen here, too. Yeah, the amount of output that one engineer can do will go up, but that does not mean that that does not mean that we'll have less engineers. It just means that eventually the number of, the amount of work out there will grow. But there are like going to be growing pains.
所以，每次效率提高和工人效率提高时，我们都会看到需求也随之增加，因为成本降低了。所以我认为我们也会在这里看到这种情况发生。是的，一个工程师的产出量会增加，但这并不意味着我们需要的工程师会减少。这只是意味着最终工作量会增长。但会有成长的阵痛。
And I think we also have the problem that a lot of people have gone and pursued degrees in careers in computer science because it's been a very lucrative field for a long time. and there may be a glut, there may be an oversupply right now. It's kind of hard to say. I mean, hiring is very tight at a lot of tech companies. And for a period, it seemed like that was because of the, you know, there was, was it 2021 or 2022 where there was just a really bad year for tech market contracted a bit.
而且我认为我们还面临一个问题，那就是很多人去攻读计算机科学学位并从事相关职业，因为长期以来这是一个非常有利可图的领域。现在可能供过于求了。很难说。我的意思是，许多科技公司的招聘非常紧张。有一段时间，似乎是因为，你知道，是 2021 年还是 2022 年，科技市场确实经历了一段非常糟糕的时期，收缩了一些。
There was a lot of like uncertainty because of world events. And like COVID was kind of weird for the hiring market in general. But after 2023, 2024, 2025, it's hard to argue that like big tech is in a bad place, right? Like big tech companies in general, not just big tech, but tech companies in general seem to be doing, seem to be having a pretty good time. So why is there less demand for for engineers? Is it still really just the case that despite the good times that tech companies feel like there's a lot of uncertainty and so they don't want to. you know, hire a lot of people and expand their, you know, how much they're paying out every two weeks in salary? Maybe. Is it that they're seeing a lot of, you know, returns from using AI tools internally?
由于世界事件，有很多不确定性。而且新冠疫情对整个招聘市场来说也有些奇怪。但在 2023、2024、2025 年之后，很难说大型科技公司处于糟糕的境地，对吧？像大型科技公司，不仅仅是大型科技公司，科技公司总体上似乎做得不错，似乎过得还不错。那么为什么对工程师的需求减少了呢？难道真的是因为尽管形势大好，科技公司仍然觉得有很多不确定性，所以他们不想招聘很多人并扩大他们每两周支付的工资支出吗？也许吧。是因为他们看到内部使用人工智能工具带来了很多回报吗？
Maybe. It could also just be that a lot of the thing that's driving the good times in tech right now, a lot of the things that are driving AI revolutions, the AI revolution, is powered by a relatively small number of people. And that may be the case. I mean, you see like these crazy deals where supposedly meta is paying, you know, ludicrous sums of money to hire people. And, you know, why are tech companies paying so much for people who are experts in ML? And it seems to be because they're getting very good results out of these relatively small teams who have this very rare knowledge of how to build these AI models.
也许吧。也可能只是因为目前推动科技行业繁荣的很多东西，推动人工智能革命的很多东西，是由相对少数的人驱动的。这可能是事实。我的意思是，你看到像 Meta 这样疯狂的交易，据说支付了巨额资金来招聘人才。而且，为什么科技公司为机器学习专家支付这么多钱？这似乎是因为他们从这些拥有稀缺知识、知道如何构建人工智能模型的小团队中获得了非常好的结果。
and they don't need, you know, 10 or 20,000 engineers to go, you know, turn out a whole pile of code. They need a small team of people who can go, you know, train and design a model. And that maybe just doesn't require the same type of software engineer that is on the market right now. Anyway, so those were a lot of words. Well, let me, we'll describe this for the listener. I was interested while you were talking about that. I mean, there's the the website
他们不需要 1 万或 2 万名工程师去生产一大堆代码。他们需要一个小团队，能够去训练和设计一个模型。这可能并不需要市场上目前那种类型的软件工程师。总之，这些话太多了。好吧，让我，我们为听众描述一下。你谈论这个的时候我很感兴趣。我的意思是，有一个网站
TrueUp.io slash layoffs which tracks layoffs. And admittedly December, and we're only halfway through January, but it's quite low. But I had never noticed that there's all this other information slash stats.
TrueUp.io/layoffs，它追踪裁员情况。诚然，12 月份，我们才过了一月份的一半，但裁员人数相当低。但我从未注意到还有所有这些其他信息/统计数据。
And the one that was relevant to what I guess we're talking about right now is kind of hiring and outlook. And if you can look at big tech employees, it shows two graphs actually and goes back to 2014, and you see this little black line that by 2016 is disappeared off the top of the chart,
与我们现在谈论的内容相关的是招聘和前景。如果你看看大型科技公司的员工，它实际上显示了两个图表，可以追溯到 2014 年，你会看到那条黑色的小线，到 2016 年已经从图表顶部消失了，
and that's Amazon, because they have 1.6 roughly million employees at this point. And you can notice that, yeah, since 2022, December 31st, so I guess the beginning of 23, it's kind of been flat, if not down, on average. Like definitely Amazon peaked back at the end of 2021,
那是亚马逊，因为他们此时大约有 160 万名员工。你可以注意到，是的，自 2022 年 12 月 31 日以来，也就是 23 年初，平均而言，它一直持平，甚至有所下降。亚马逊肯定在 2021 年底达到了顶峰，
and then their employee count has dropped and not recovered to that point. And then definitely, I'm sure you've heard the reporting that's been done of Amazon talking about how they're going to be employing, quote unquote, employing or using robots more and have less need to. Yeah, but the interesting thing here, you know, some people have the theory that, oh, this is happening because AI is replacing the software engineering jobs. and I think that it's very unlikely that that's true because go back to that graph for a second.
然后他们的员工人数下降了，并没有恢复到那个水平。而且肯定，我相信你已经听到了关于亚马逊的报道，谈论他们将如何更多地雇佣，引用“雇佣”或使用机器人，而减少对人的需求。是的，但这里有趣的是，有些人有一种理论，认为这发生是因为人工智能正在取代软件工程工作。我认为这不太可能是真的，因为回到那个图表看一下。
Actually, go back to what you just had. What was, it just had a list of important dates. Yeah, yeah, well, there's a ton of stuff. I mean, just to skip around to all this different stuff, I'll link this website in the show notes.
实际上，回到你刚才展示的。那是什么，它只是有一个重要日期列表。是的，是的，有很多东西。我的意思是，只是跳过所有这些不同的东西，我会把这个网站放在节目说明中。
Go back and what was it. It had the date for when chat GPT launched. 3.1 years ago on November 30th. Yeah, 2022. Go back to that chart. The hiring sort of like peaked in 2022. Because I think was it, 2021 was the bad year for tech, maybe it was 2022. It was one of those two years.
回到它是什么。它有 ChatGPT 发布的时间。3.1 年前，11 月 30 日。是的，2022 年。回到那个图表。招聘在 2022 年达到了顶峰。因为我认为是 2021 年是科技行业的糟糕年份，也许是 2022 年。那是那两年中的一年。
I think it's hard to believe that in 2022, that across the board, tech company leadership said, oh, hey, this AI thing is here. That means that we should stop hiring because, you know, our software engineers are going to be so much more efficient because of this. Like, 2022, I don't think everybody had drank the Kool-Aid yet, right? Like, maybe some people did, but like even you and I, you know, we were not on the AI hype train in 2022. So I think that there's some other explanation going on. I don't think that Amazon or Microsoft are hiring more people or doing layoffs because they decided in 2022 that AI could make their software engineering.
我认为很难相信在 2022 年，科技公司领导层全面表示，哦，嘿，这个人工智能东西来了。这意味着我们应该停止招聘，因为我们的软件工程师会因为这个而变得更有效率。像 2022 年，我不认为每个人都喝了那杯“酷爱饮料”（被洗脑），对吧？也许有些人喝了，但即使是你和我，我们也没有在 2022 年赶上人工智能炒作的列车。所以我认为还有其他解释。我不认为亚马逊或微软招聘更多人或进行裁员是因为他们决定在 2022 年人工智能可以让他们的软件工程
workforce more efficient. I don't buy that. I think it's some combination of other factors. And I think, like, maybe part of it is a lot of these companies have to deploy their capital now to make these huge investments in hardware to train these AI models. And so maybe that's where they're investing their money instead of in personnel. Maybe it's because, you know, they don't need as big teams to build these models. I don't know.
劳动力更有效率。我不买账。我认为这是其他因素的某种组合。而且我认为，也许部分原因是这些公司中的许多公司现在必须部署他们的资本，对硬件进行巨额投资来训练这些人工智能模型。所以也许这就是他们投资资金的地方，而不是投资在人员上。也许是因为他们不需要那么大的团队来构建这些模型。我不知道。
I mean, yes. So I switched over to artificial analysis, which funnily enough, only goes back to March of 2023, which is four months after November of 2022, which is when ChatGBTGT launched. And I recall really being like, what is the word, AI pilled when Claude 3.5 was out. So that was like middle to late 2024. So I've been using cursor ever since early 2025. I think I bought my first subscription in January and then realized within a month that Nvidia was paying for our subscription.
我的意思是，是的。所以我切换到了 Artificial Analysis，有趣的是，它只追溯到 2023 年 3 月，也就是 2022 年 11 月 ChatGPT 发布四个月后。我记得当 Claude 3.5 出来时，我真的被“人工智能洗脑”了。那是 2024 年中后期。所以我从 2025 年初就开始使用 Cursor 了。我想我在 1 月份买了我的第一个订阅，然后在一个月内意识到 Nvidia 正在为我们的订阅付费。
So I only paid for a month. But I had been using like the online, you know, chat GPT and friends for helping out with coding. And so, yeah, it wasn't until 2024. So it took a full year and a half. half until I started using these tools. And I didn't have my mind blown until, I don't know, the Claude 3.7, which was in April, March. Similar for me. So I think it's hard to believe that AI, that the increase in worker efficiency in the software
所以我只付了一个月的钱。但我一直在使用在线的 ChatGPT 和类似工具来帮助编码。所以，是的，直到 2024 年。所以花了一年半的时间，我才开始使用这些工具。直到 Claude 3.7 出来，我才感到震惊，那是在 4 月、3 月。我也一样。所以我认为很难相信人工智能，即软件领域因人工智能而提高的工人效率，是科技招聘下降的唯一原因。而且我认为这更像是多种不同因素的组合。如果你不是人工智能，你有什么理论吗？有点像我刚才说明的，为什么现在科技行业的每个人都做得很好。它几乎在某种程度上是因为人工智能。所有做得好的大型科技公司，之所以做得好，是因为他们在人工智能经济中占有一席之地。而且我认为你不需要，你需要一种不同类型的劳动力来成为一家人工智能科技公司，而不是以前需要的。
field due to AI is the sole reason for tech hiring falling off. And I think it's more likely that it's like a combination of multiple different factors. And do you have any theories for if it's not, if it's not AI? Kind of what I illustrated that why are all the like everybody is doing well in tech right now. It pretty much is doing well because of AI in some way, shape, or form. All the big, all the big tech players who are doing well are doing well because they have some part in the AI economy. and I think that you don't need, you need a different sort of workforce to be an AI tech company than you needed before.
我认为这就是原因。看看微软或 Google，现在对他们来说什么最重要？是构建他们的人工智能、超大规模云，并训练世界上最好的模型。招聘 1 万名初级工程师能帮助 Gemini 变得更好吗？不，可能帮助 Gemini 变得更好的事情是去招聘那 5 个关键专家，他们知道你在人工智能这个特定领域、这个特定利基领域目前遇到问题所需要的东西。我不认为这些公司需要像，稀缺的
I think that's what it is. That look at, look at like Microsoft or Google, like what's important for them right now? It's building out like their AI, their hyper-skiller cloud and in training the world's best models. Do you need, is hiring 10,000 junior engineers going to help make Gemini better? No, probably the thing that's going to help make Gemini better is going in hiring, you know, the five, you know, key experts who know the thing that you need for this particular part of, this particular niche area of AI where you've got a problem right now. That I don't, I don't think it's, these companies need like, rare.
专业知识现在，稀缺的专业知识正在驱动科技经济，而不是这些庞大的劳动力，不是仅仅靠人力，不是仅仅靠敲代码的猴子输出代码。而且我认为，因为这些公司投入了这么多钱来建设数据中心，建设计算硬件，他们当然自然而然地，你不能在增加 1 万名员工的同时，又去建设数十亿、数十亿美元的数据中心。你确实有有限的资金。所以我认为这就是，他们选择投资计算资源。
expertise right now, rare expertise is driving the tech economy right now, not, you know, these large workforces of, not like just solely person power, you know, not just code monkeys spitting out code. And I think that, I think that also, because these companies are deploying so much money to build out data centers, to build out compute hardware, they, they of course naturally are all you can't grow your workforce by 10,000 employees and also, you know, go build, you know, billions and billions of dollars of data centers. Like, you do have a limited amount of money. And so I think that's the, they're choosing to invest in, in the compute resources.
而且我认为还有其他因素。我确实认为经济中存在很多不确定性。关于是否存在人工智能泡沫存在不确定性，由于目前世界政治存在不确定性。所以我认为这也是其中的一部分。但最后一个论点，我现在觉得它不如 2020 年时那么有说服力了。
And I think there's other factors. I do think that there's a lot of uncertainty in the economy. there's uncertainty about whether there's an AI bubble, there's uncertainty because of, you know, the politics of the world right now. And so I think that's part of it too. But that last argument, I find less compelling now than I did in 2020.
有趣。你怎么看？你的理论是什么？我的意思是，关于科技招聘和企业资本分配向基础设施建设或计算支出与员工支出倾斜的话题。我想我没有太多，我真的没有花太多时间去思考这个问题。我要说的是，呼应你刚才谈到的，
Interesting. What do you think? What's your theories here? I mean, on the topic of tech hiring and corporate capital allocation towards, you know, infrastructure build or compute spend versus employee spend. I don't think I have a ton of, I don't really spend a lot of time thinking about that. I will say to echo what, you know, you just talked about,
我有一种不断演变的观点，或者说不是演变的观点，但我有过一些时刻，我意识到确实需要专家来正确使用这些工具。作为该领域的专家，你并没有真正意识到这一点，因为你只是要求这些工具做你想做的事情，因为你知道那是你想要的东西。
I have had the evolving view, or not evolving view, but I had a kind of moments where I realized that experts really are required. to use these tools correctly. And as an expert in a domain, you don't really realize it because you're just asking these tools to do what you want it to do because you know that's the thing you want.
但当你进入一个你不是专家的垂直领域，并且你确实关心代码质量时。所以，你知道，如果你不在乎，那没关系。但如果你试图在某种语言中获得地道的解决方案，无论是 Python 还是 Rust，
But when you go to a vertical that you are not an expert in and you do care about code quality. So, you know, vibe coding, if you don't care, it doesn't matter. But if you are trying to get like the idiomatic solution in some language, whether it's Python or Rust,
而你不是专家，你不知道库的表面积以及库中的算法或 API 中的 API 和方法。然后你把那个作为 PR 发布到某个地方。当专家看它时，你会很快意识到它不一定是在做最佳实践的地道事情。我最近在使用 Rust 时就有过这种经历。所以有区别。
and you're not an expert, and you don't know the surface area of the libraries and the algorithms in the libraries or the APIs and the methods in the APIs. And then you post that as a PR somewhere. You are going to realize very quickly when experts take a look at it that it's not necessarily doing like the best practice idiomatic thing. And I had that experience when working with Rust recently. And so there's a difference.
你知道，当你不在乎代码质量时，就随便写写。或者抱歉，当你不在乎代码质量时，就随便写写。但当你关心时，专业知识不仅是必要的，我会说根据你试图完成的任务的复杂性，它是必不可少的。而且我认为作为一个通常在专业领域或我的专业领域运作的人，你并没有真正注意到你有多，因为每当它做了一些你知道不是你想要的事情时，你只是告诉它。
You know, when you can't. about the code quality, you know, vibe code away. Or sorry, when you don't care about the code quality, vibe code away. But when you do care, expertise is like not only necessary, I would say essential, depending on the complexity of the task that you're trying to do. And I think as like someone that operates typically in a domain of expertise or like my expertise, you don't really notice how much you're, because anytime it does something that you know is not what you wanted, you just tell it.
不，不，不，不，不。请使用这个库中的这个东西。总之，这呼应了你所说的，是的，我不知道是否只有资深工程师才是人们所需要的，但我绝对认为专业知识，尽管这些模型真的、真的很好，但很多时候它会走错路，你需要能够纠正它。如果你不知道你走错了路，
No, no, no, no, no. please use this thing from this library. And anyway, so that kind of echoes what you're saying is that, yeah, I don't know if it's a staff level engineer that is all that people need, but definitely I think expertise, even though that these models are really, really good still, that a lot of the times it goes down the wrong path and you need to be able to correct that. And if you don't know that you've gone down a wrong path,
这对很多初级人员来说可能是一个问题，那将是一个问题。但我甚至不认为这一定是问题，因为我认为我们在人工智能的采用方面仍然处于非常早期的阶段，即使在软件工程领域也是如此。我不知道是否有关于大型或小型科技公司中员工使用人工智能的百分比的公开数据。但我敢打赌，我敢打赌它比你想象的要少得多，因为正如我常说的，惯性在软件行业是王道，切换到新工具、新工作方式是可怕的，人们真正去那样做需要很长时间。所以如果你告诉我，大型科技公司中只有 25% 的员工在使用，比如大型科技公司中只有 25% 的软件工程师在使用人工智能，我不会感到惊讶。
which is probably going to be the case for a lot of junior folks, that's going to be a problem. But I don't even think that that's necessarily the problem because I think we're still very early in the adoption of AI, even within the software engineering. I don't know what percentage of, I don't know whether there's public data on what percentage of employees at big or small tech companies are using AI. But I bet you, I bet you it's a lot less than you think because, as I always like to say, inertia is king in the software industry and switching to new tools. pools into new ways of working is scary and it takes a long time for people to actually go and do that. So if you told me that only 25% of employees at big tech companies were using, like 25% of software engineers at big tech companies were using AI, I wouldn't be surprised.
我认为这可能取决于公司。我认为可能有些公司达到了 80%、90%，如果不是全部的话。然后有些公司比例非常、非常低。而且我不认为任何大公司接近那个高水平，因为我不认为像 Google 规模的公司，甚至像 Nvidia 规模的公司，我不认为你能那么快达到那些数字。我想，是的，也许是一家小公司。是的，但这些非常大的科技公司，它们没有，有很多本地化的实践和文化，东西需要很长时间才能渗透到整个公司。是的，那是真的。我的意思是，对于一家拥有少数
I think it's probably company dependent. I think there's probably some companies where it's like 80, 90%, if not all. And then there's other companies where it's really, really low. And I don't think that there's any, I don't think that any of the big companies are anywhere near that high because I don't think that like a company of like Google scale or even like at an Nvidia scale. I don't think that you can get to those numbers that quickly. I think, yeah, maybe a smaller company. Yeah, but these really large tech companies, they don't have like there, there's a lot of like localized practice in culture and it takes a long time for stuff to trickle down throughout the entire. company. Yeah, that's true. I mean, it's way, way easier for a startup with, you know, a handful of
员工的初创公司来说，全部利用这些工具，也就是 100% 的人，要比拥有数万名员工的公司容易得多。想想看，一旦，一旦，你知道，给它五年时间，然后我们就会开始看到这个行业的饱和，我想。不，它不会，我不认为需要五年。我认为达到 80% 到 90%。在某个时候，让我这样说。在某个时候，
folks to all be leveraging these tools, aka 100% of them, versus some company with tens of thousands of employees. And just think what, just think what it's going to be like once, once, you know, give it, give it five years and then we'll start seeing saturation in this industry, I think. No, it's not, I don't think it's going to take five years. I think to to get to 80 to 90%. Like at some point, let me put it this way. At some point,
软件行业在版本控制之前有一段时间，对吧？现在不使用版本控制是不可想象的。而且在某种程度上，几乎不使用 Git 是不可想象的。而且我认为人工智能辅助编码需要五年时间才能达到那个水平，即人们不使用人工智能工具来编写代码是不可想象的。
there was like a time before version control in the software industry, right? And now it's unthinkable to not use version control. And like almost to some degree, it's almost unthinkable to not use Git specifically. And like I think it'll take five years for AI-assisted coding to reach that level, where it's unthinkable that people aren't using AI tools to write code.
多少年？五年。我不同意。我认为会快得多。而且我不，我们不能，我们知道有多少工程师吗？Nvidia 有多少员工？
How many years? Five years. I disagree. I think it's going to be way sooner. And I don't, we can't, do we know how many engineers? How many employees does NVIDIA have?
大约 3 万？截至 2024 年底有 3.6 万。所以那可能已经过时了。我的意思是，我们必须编辑这个。但在 Cursor 仪表板中，使用 Cursor 的人。而且我们的……是的，伙计，我们是人工智能公司。
Like 30,000? 36,000 as of 2024 end of year. So that might be out of date. And I mean, we have to redact this. But in the cursor dashboard, people that are using cursor. And of our... Yeah, dude, we're the AI company.
我的意思是，我们是世界上最大的公司。你刚才说了大公司。而且，Adobe 有多少员工？因为 Sean 说 Adobe 有大约 8000 人。Adobe 有多少员工？超过 3 万？好吧，那比例较低。但就像 Nvidia 大约 3.6 万人中，
I mean, we're the biggest company in the world. You just said the big companies. And also, how many employees does Adobe have? Because Sean said there was like 8,000 people at Adobe. How many employees at Adobe? Over 30,000? Okay, so that's a lower ratio. But like, of the 36,000 roughly people at Nvidia,
你认为有多少人在工程部门？写代码的。我不知道。我不知道。这是一个好问题。我不知道工程与非工程的比例是多少。但这对于 Nvidia 来说也很复杂，因为我们既有软件工程师也有硬件工程师。是的。
how many do you think are in engineering? better writing code. I don't know. I don't know. That's a good question. I don't know what like the percentage is of engineering versus non-engineering. But it's also complicated for Nvidia because we have both software and hardware engineers. Yeah.
总之，我认为当我最近做演讲时，你知道，我问观众有多少人，你知道，认为人工智能是，我不想回到……我认为大约有 1.8 万名工程师在 NVIDIA。在 1.8 万人中，或者至少登录过 Cursor？我不知道。我认为基于此，我认为这强烈暗示这意味着我们已经自动将很大一部分人纳入了 Cursor，比如某种大型工程交易。我不认为是自动注册。我认为你必须真正输入你的电子邮件并下载它，你才会出现在这些指标中。好吧，那确实令人印象深刻。我会更有兴趣看到关于
Anyways, I think it's when I was giving a talk recently, you know, I asked the audience what percentage of folks, you know, consider AI as I don't want to go back. to... I think it's about 18,000 are engineers at NVIDIA. S-a-und out of 18,000, or at least have logged into Cursor? I don't know that. I think based on that, I think that that just means that I strongly suspect that that would mean that we've auto-enrolled some large part in Cursor, like some large engineering deal. I don't think it's auto-enrollment. I think you literally have to punch your email in and download it in order for you to show up in these metrics. Okay, that is pretty impressive. I would be more interested in seeing like numbers about
谁在积极使用它，而不仅仅是谁登录过一次。但是，但这只是因为可能有研究人员、产品管理和其他事情填补了一定数量的角色。总之，我的理论是，这些东西已经，我们无法回头了，因为它太有用了。而且我也认为，可能我最大胆的预测是，人们将不再把这些模型视为缺乏智能。很多人说这不是，你知道，它不是，我不想用“有知觉”这个词，但它不是人类智能的等价物。
who's like actively using it, not just who's logged in one time. But, but that's just that, because there's probably research people and product management and other things that fills out some amount of roles. Anyways, my, my theory is that this stuff is, is already like, we can't go back because it's so useful. And I also think that probably my boldest prediction, is that people will stop treating these models as unintelligent. A lot of people say that this is not, you know, it's not, I don't want to use the word sentient, but it's not the equivalent of like human intelligence.
而且我认为我们正在为大语言模型添加的所有这些不同的功能，首先是 RAG，检索增强，然后是记忆。你知道，这正是他们目前正在研究的方向。在此之上还有上下文压缩，你可以认为这是一种信息合成的形式。就像你只是……看看你。你只是……
And I think that all these different features that we are adding on to LLMs, first it was reg, retrieval, augmentation, then it was memories. You know, that's what they're kind of currently working on. On top of that is like context compression, which you could argue as a form of synthesizing information. Like you're just... Look at you. You're just...
你认为你不会被“书呆子狙击”去研究所有这些东西。我们会看到的。我的观点是，在我看来，你只是在描述设计智能的过程。就像什么是人类智能，你知道？我们检索信息的能力。我们做到了。搜索引擎，我们从不同来源合成信息并得出，你知道，合成事实或什么的。记忆，你知道，很多智能，Jeopardy，
You think you're not going to get nerd sniped into working on in all things. We'll see. My point being here, though, is that in my opinion, you're just describing the process of like designing intelligence. Like what is human intelligence, you know? Our ability to retrieve information. We do that. search engines, our ability to like synthesize information from different sources and come up with, you know, a synthesized fact or whatever. Memory, you know, a lot of intelligence, jeopardy,
所有的游戏节目。它只是以一种你可以，就像我们实际上正在做的方式存储信息。如果你必须描述人类智能的不同方面，它实际上就是人们正在添加到大语言模型中的不同东西。它起初只是像这个标记生成器，你知道，输入标记，输出标记，无论什么，但现在它是所有这些加上
all the game shows. It's just storing information in a way where you can, like we're literally going. If you had to describe the different aspects of the intelligence of humans, it is literally the different things that people are adding on to like LLMs. It started off just as this like token generator and you know feed tokens in tokens out whatever but now it's like all of that plus
这些东西，你知道，上下文压缩和信息检索和记忆，在什么点上我们承认我们只是，我们正在设计智能系统，哦，好吧，它没有意识，因此
this stuff you know context compression and and information retrieval and memory and at what point do we like admit that we're just like we're designing intelligent systems that like oh okay it's not it doesn't have consciousness and therefore
它没有知觉，但你知道，仅仅因为飞机飞行的方式不像鸟，并不意味着它不能飞行，你知道我的意思吗？是的，我们正在构建智能系统，我们将智能装进了瓶子，并正在为这些模型添加智能特性，它们有时所做的事情令人震惊。而且我认为有很多，我不知道这是否只是人类的傲慢，认为哦，你知道，它不像我们，你知道，它不像我们那样思考，好吧，当然，飞机不像鸟那样飞行。并不意味着它们不能飞行。有些人会争辩说。它们飞得甚至比鸟还好。而且我认为我们正在接近一个点，这些系统将
it's not sentient but you know just because a plane doesn't fly like a bird doesn't mean it can't fly you know what i mean yeah it is we are building intelligence systems we have put intelligence in a bottle and we are adding intelligence features to these models and it is mind-blowing what they do sometimes you know and i think there's just a lot of i don't know if it's just the hubris of humans and like arrogance that like oh you know it's it's not it's not like us you know it doesn't think like us well okay sure planes don't fly like birds. Doesn't mean they can't fly. Some would argue. They fly even better than birds. And I think that like we're, we're approaching a point where these systems are going to
比人类思考得更好。而且在某种程度上，这怎么不是比人类水平的智能更好，你知道？我们还没到那一步。我只是说我们正在接近它，但我听了所有这些播客，人们说，啊，你知道，我们通过了图灵测试，但它，你知道，我们某种程度上反驳了这一点。所以，你在说什么？我们已经超越了它。这太棒了。我们本该为通过图灵测试设立一个全球性的节日。总之，是的，无论如何。但正如我妻子告诉我的，我对所有这些话题都有激进的观点。而且大多数人，你知道，她说，她告诉我我的观点超出了奥弗顿之窗，人们不像我那样准备好接受即将到来的机器神统治者。我们得暂停一下，因为我有一个书推荐，但我得去拿那本书。好吧。但我的意思是，我想我们可以在我走的时候谈话。只是，你知道，我必须走进……
think better than humans. And how is that not like it's, it's better than human level intelligence at a certain point, you know? We're not there yet. I'm just saying we're approaching it, but I listen to all these podcasts of people being like, ah, you know, we, we passed the Turing test, but it's, you know, we kind of disprove that. And so it's, what are you talking about? We blew past it. It's amazing. We should have had a global holiday for passing the Turing test. And it's just, yeah, anyways. But as my wife tells me, I have like radical views on all these topics. And most people, you know, she says, she tells me that my views are outside the Overton window and that people aren't ready to accept our machine god overlords that are around the corner as much as I am. We got to pause for a second because I have a book recommendation, but I have to go get the book. All right. But I mean, I guess we can actually talk as I walk. It's just that, you know, I have to walk into the...
我希望这本书。我希望这本书是我两本半书前刚读完的那本书。我保证。我保证你没有读过这本书，因为……好吧。它完全属于一个单独的类别。在 Bryce 带回他的书之后，我会给出我的书推荐。你还在吗？
I hope this book. I hope this book is the book that I just finished reading two and a half books ago. I guarantee you. I guarantee you you have not read this book because... All right. It's in a completely separate category. I will give my book recommendation after Bryce comes back with his book. Are you still here?
是的。我去拿了一个蛋白棒，但我回到了我的办公桌。你错过了一些目标，我想你必须剪掉，因为 Ramona 正在预约医生。但不，我不是在找科技书。我是在找宗教书。你知道吗？我不确定这是否在播客中提到过，但我从 LSU 获得的学位，我的起源
Yes. I went to grab a protein bar, but I am back at my desk. You missed some goals. that I think you will have to cut because Ramona was making a doctor's appointment. But no, I was not looking for the tech books. I was looking for the religion books. Did you know? I'm not sure if this has come out in the podcast, but my degree from LSU, which my origin
故事已经在他们的手测中出现过，但我从 LSU 获得的学位，我主修应用数学，但辅修比较宗教研究，因为我必须选修一门关于宗教的课程作为选修课。教授非常好。她非常严厉，但她非常好。我就想，这很有趣。所以我选修了一堆其他课程。所以我发现研究各种宗教非常迷人。
story has been on their hand test, but my degree from LSU, I have a major in applied mathematics, but a minor in comparative religious studies because I had to take one course on religion as like an elective. And the professor was really good. She was really tough, but she was really good. And I was like, this is fun. And so I took a bunch of other courses. And so I find the study of various religions very fascinating.
故事一直在他们手中测试，但我从路易斯安那州立大学毕业时，主修应用数学，辅修比较宗教学，因为我必须选修一门宗教课程作为选修课。那位教授非常棒。她要求很严格，但确实教得很好。我觉得这很有趣，于是又修了许多其他课程。因此，我发现研究各种宗教非常引人入胜。
And we had, that was right round when I was getting to tech. And I ended up taking this one course and sort of like the Buddhist philosophy of the mind. And one of these two books, has a great section talking about, like, Buddhist theory on how the mind works. And I remember reading it. And there was a particular chapter on, like, memory, and, like, talking about how do our minds retrieve a memory? Like, how does that work? And I remember reading that and thinking, huh, this is fascinating. I wonder if someday this will be applicable to people building intelligent, you know, computers. And the books are, I think it's this one, the psychology of awakening or this one,
当时我正好开始接触科技领域。我最终选修了一门关于佛教心识哲学的课程。这两本书中的其中一本，有一章非常精彩，讨论了佛教关于心智运作的理论。我记得当时读到这里，里面有一章专门讲记忆，探讨我们的心智是如何提取记忆的？这是怎么运作的？我读的时候心想，哇，这太迷人了。不知道未来有一天这是否能应用于构建智能计算机。这两本书，我想应该是这本《觉醒心理学》（The Psychology of Awakening），或者是这本，
the resonance of emptiness. Let me look in the table of contents. Are these textbooks? Or are they? These are textbooks. Yes. I see. All right. I'll put them on my list. I got a lot of books on my list right now, though. But if you are able to pinpoint which one it is, although I'm pretty sure an LLM could answer this. I'm sure it could. And one of them in particular had a section on memory. It could be possibly one of the other books, but I'm almost certain it's one of these two. We're using Gemini 3 folks because Chatchip-T has been broken for a number of days.
《空性的共鸣》（The Resonance of Emptiness）。让我查查目录。这些是教科书吗？还是？这些是教科书。是的。我明白了。好的，我会把它们加入我的书单。不过我现在书单上已经有很多书了。但如果你能确定是哪一本，虽然我敢肯定大语言模型（LLM）能回答这个问题。我肯定它能。其中一本特别有一章讲记忆。也可能是另外那本，但我几乎确定是这两本中的一本。各位，我们现在用的是 Gemini 3，因为 ChatGPT 已经瘫痪好几天了。
Both books explore the intersection of Buddhism and psychology, but they approach the topic of memory in different ways. The book that focuses more explicitly on the psychological and philosophical mechanics of memory is the resonance of emptiness. a Buddhist inspiration for contemporary psychotherapy by Gay Watson, Memory in Reson of Emptiness. In this book, Watson discusses memory primarily in the context of how our sense of self, in quotations, is constructed. She explores how memory acts as a bridge that creates a false sense of continuity and identity. The key chapter, memory is discussed most significantly in chapter four,
这两本书都探讨了佛教与心理学的交叉点，但它们处理记忆主题的方式不同。更明确聚焦于记忆的心理学和哲学机制的那本书是《空性的共鸣：当代心理治疗的佛教启示》（The Resonance of Emptiness: A Buddhist Inspiration for Contemporary Psychotherapy），作者是盖伊·沃森（Gay Watson）。在这本书中，沃森主要在“自我感”是如何构建的背景下讨论记忆。她探讨了记忆如何作为一座桥梁，创造出一种虚假的连续性和身份感。关于记忆的关键章节，讨论最深入的是第四章，
the consciousness that views some ideas of the self. The argument Watson explains that our mental continuity is the result of habit, memory, and conditioning. She argues that what we perceive as a solid, in quotation's eye, is actually a construct built from aggregates of past sensory perceptions that have, quote, unquote, hardened into memories. Did that sound right? Yes. I'll have to read a little bit later and see if I can find the specific.
即观察自我观念的意识。沃森解释说，我们的心理连续性是习惯、记忆和条件反射的结果。她认为，我们所感知的那个坚固的“我”，实际上是由过去的感官知觉聚合而成的结构，这些知觉已经“固化”成了记忆。听起来对吗？是的。我稍后得读一下，看看能不能找到具体内容。
Yeah, that sounds about right. To be confirmed next episode when Bryce has read a little bit. little bit and once he has, once he has nailed it down, I will add it up to my books to read, folks. The book that I was hoping he was going to say was Permutation City by Greg Egan. Have you heard of that book? I have not. I was, this will be our last story because we got to go soon. I was listening to another podcast and a future podcast.
是的，听起来差不多。下期节目等布莱斯（Bryce）读过之后再确认。等他彻底搞清楚了，我就把它加到我的阅读清单里，各位。我本来希望他提到的是格雷格·伊根（Greg Egan）的《排列城》（Permutation City）。你听说过这本书吗？我没听说过。这是我们最后一个故事了，因为我们很快得走了。我当时在听另一个播客，一个关于未来的播客。
Got to go? Where are we going? What? I got to go to dinner at my now wife's mothers tonight. And anyways, there will be a future episode that I'm going to record in the next week or so called The Podcast Purge, which is about all the podcasts that I've removed from my list of podcasts, which it'll be a backup episode for when, whatever, I've run out of episodes and I don't have time to record one.
得走了？我们要去哪？什么？我今晚得去我现在的岳母家吃晚饭。总之，未来几周内我会录制一期节目，叫《播客大清洗》（The Podcast Purge），内容是关于我从播客列表中移除的所有播客。当我不小心听完了所有节目，或者没时间录制新节目时，这会作为备用集。
And anyways, this podcast did not get purged. It's called the Peterman Pod. And it is interviews with high-level ICs at different companies and talking about how to get promoted and advice, etc. It's pretty decent more because he talks to folks at different companies, meta, alphabet, blah, blah, blah. In one of the more recent interviews, he talks to Boris Churney, who is the author of Claude Code.
总之，这个播客没有被清洗掉。它叫《Peterman Pod》。内容是对不同公司的高级个人贡献者（IC）进行采访，讨论如何获得晋升以及建议等。它相当不错，主要是因为他采访了不同公司的人，比如 Meta、Alphabet 等等。在最近的一次采访中，他采访了 Claude Code 的作者鲍里斯·切尔尼（Boris Churney）。
And in that episode, Link in the Show Notes, he discusses the interview process when he was interviewing at Anthropic. And he mentions that at some point, his book, favorite book or something, comes up and he says it's a book by Greg Egan. He doesn't actually name the book. So I don't actually know if this is the book he mentioned, but I asked Gemini, there was a Peterman Pod where Boris Turney was being interviewed, and he mentioned a book by Greg Egan. What was the name of the book? And the book that the LLM came up with was Permutation City. And the remark that Boris made was that, in general, whenever he brings
在那一集里（节目说明中有链接），他讨论了在 Anthropic 面试时的过程。他提到在某个时候，谈到了他最喜欢的书，他说那是格雷格·伊根的一本书。他实际上没有说出书名。所以我不知道这是否就是他提到的那本书，但我问了 Gemini：有一个采访鲍里斯·切尔尼的《Peterman Pod》，他提到了格雷格·伊根的一本书，书名是什么？大语言模型给出的书名是《排列城》。鲍里斯当时评论说，通常情况下，每当他提起
this book up, no one's ever heard about it, let alone read it. And he was talking or being interviewed by a panel of folks. And not only had all like three of them or all of them heard of the book, they had all read it. And then instantly they were like, oh, yeah, yeah, that book is good. What about these books? And the book is fantastic. It's not as good as the three-body problem trilogy, which is my favorite books of all time. But it is very thought provocative.
这本书时，从来没人听说过，更别提读过了。当时采访他的是一个小组。结果不仅那三个人或所有人都听说过这本书，而且他们全都读过。然后他们立刻说，哦，对对对，那本书很棒。那这几本呢？这本书太棒了。虽然不如我最喜欢的《三体》三部曲，但它非常发人深省。
If you like the TV show Pantheon, which apparently Pantheon is based on a set of short stories by Ken Leo, who is the individual that translated the three-body problem, which was originally authored, I believe, by Jin Liu, who is a Chinese author and wrote it in Chinese. Anyway, so I do plan to go read the Ken Liu short stories that Pantheon was based on. I think that was Joao, the recommended that show. Once again, not the world's best show,
如果你喜欢电视剧《万神殿》（Pantheon），显然《万神殿》是基于刘宇昆（Ken Liu）的一系列短篇小说改编的，他也是《三体》的译者。而《三体》的原作者我相信是刘慈欣，一位中国作家，用中文写的。总之，我确实打算去读刘宇昆的短篇小说，也就是《万神殿》的原著。我想是若昂（Joao）推荐的那部剧。再说一次，那不是世界上最好的剧，
but it is very thought-provocative. If anybody has suggestions, similar to Permutation City, I'm on a massive AI-uploaded intelligence kick, and I just finished reading Diaspora by Greg Egan. Wasn't as good as Permutation City. I'm in the middle of reading, although this is rated R. So if you are below a certain age, do not go read this book. I was shocked at how rated R this book is.
但它非常发人深省。如果有人有类似《排列城》的推荐，我最近对 AI 上传智能题材非常着迷，我刚读完格雷格·伊根的《离散》（Diaspora）。没《排列城》那么好。我正在读另一本，不过这本书被评为 R 级（限制级）。所以如果你未成年，千万别去读。我被这本书的限制级程度震惊了。
It's called the... Rated R in what way? Like the content. Like it's... Like violence or sex, Connor? All of the above and more. I'm in fact, one of my best friends, you met him at the wedding. Victor, he recommended this book to me a while ago.
它叫……怎么个限制级法？是指内容吗？比如暴力或色情，康纳？以上皆是，甚至更多。事实上，我最好的朋友之一，你在婚礼上见过他，维克多（Victor），他很久以前就向我推荐过这本书。
and apparently also recommended Permutation City and I, for whatever reason, I usually read whatever he tells me right away, but for some reason this slipped through the cracks, and I am surprised he did not give me a warning about reading this book. I mean, I'm an adult, so it's totally fine, but it's like when you recommend someone Black Mirror, if they're going to start with Season 1, Episode 1, which is the one that involves the pig, you have to give people a warning,
显然他也推荐过《排列城》，不知为何，我通常会立刻去读他推荐的书，但这次漏掉了。我很惊讶他没给我读这本书的警告。我是说，我是成年人，所以完全没问题，但这就像你向别人推荐《黑镜》（Black Mirror）时，如果他们要从第一季第一集开始看，也就是涉及猪的那一集，你必须给人们一个警告，
and I actually tell people just skip that episode because it's just too disturbing. Anyways, the name of the book that's rated R is the metamorphosis of the prime intellect. So far, it's not lived up to the hype that my buddy Victor sold it because he said, if you like Permutation City, you have to read this book. And so far it's not as good as Permutation City. Anyways, do you have any other book recommendations while we're wrapping up this 2026 AI in predictions episode? I've been trying to work my way through the entire works of Asimov.
我甚至告诉人们直接跳过那一集，因为它太令人不安了。总之，那本限制级书的名字叫《原始智能的蜕变》（The Metamorphosis of Prime Intellect）。到目前为止，它还没达到我朋友维克多吹捧的高度，因为他说如果你喜欢《排列城》，就一定要读这本书。目前看来它不如《排列城》。总之，在我们结束这期 2026 年 AI 预测节目之前，你还有其他书推荐吗？我一直在尝试读完阿西莫夫（Asimov）的所有作品。
I've read a lot of his later stuff. I haven't read some of his like earlier stuff. What is, is the earlier stuff foundation or is the later stuff foundation? Sorry, by later stuff I mean like in his timeline. Like I've read like foundation and like onwards. I've read, I had not read a lot of the like earlier things like earlier in his timeline. One, have you seen the Apple Plus TV show? And two.
我读过很多他后期的作品。我还没读过他一些早期的作品。什么是……早期作品是《基地》（Foundation）系列吗？还是后期作品是《基地》？抱歉，我说的后期是指他创作时间线上的后期。比如我读过《基地》及以后的作品。我还没读过很多他时间线早期的一些东西。第一，你看过 Apple TV+ 的剧集了吗？第二。
Yes. And two, are you not bothered? Because I tried to get through. I think I got through one and a half of the foundation books or however many there are. and I just could not stand the time jumps. It's like I get attached to these characters and then boom, they're all gone except for one. And they're like different. No, I was always kind of fun with that.
是的。第二，你不觉得困扰吗？因为我试着读完《基地》系列，我想我读了一本半，或者不管有多少本，我实在受不了时间跨度太大。我刚对这些角色产生感情，然后砰的一声，除了一个之外，他们全都没了。而且他们变得不一样了。不，我一直觉得那挺有趣的。
It just drives me nuts. And I think that they did it very, very well in the TV show. Right now I'm on the robot series. I'm on the Robots of Dawn, which is, it's like this series of three books about a detective from Earth who goes and solves some crimes that involve robots. But my favorite one was the, is I think is it I robot? Yeah, it's iRobot, which is it's a collection of short stories by Asimov. It's 1950. And that's the book that introduces the three laws of robotics. And the short stories all involve various contradictions or paradoxes involving those three laws. And I think it's a very good book. And I think it's it really got me thinking, I think I read iro about like a year or two ago. It really got me thinking about like a year or two ago. It really got me thinking about, How are we going to actually design, you know, robots that don't kill us all?
这简直让我抓狂。我觉得电视剧里处理得非常好。我现在在看《机器人》系列。我正在看《曙光中的机器人》（The Robots of Dawn），这是关于一个地球侦探去解决一些涉及机器人犯罪的三部曲。但我最喜欢的是《我，机器人》（I, Robot），对吧？是的，是《我，机器人》，那是阿西莫夫的短篇小说集，出版于 1950 年。那本书引入了机器人三定律。这些短篇小说都涉及了围绕这三定律的各种矛盾或悖论。我觉得这是一本非常好的书。它真的让我开始思考，我想我是一两年前读的《我，机器人》。它真的让我开始思考，我们到底该如何设计那些不会把我们全杀掉的机器人？
And it's not my job, but it's somebody else's job. But good luck with that, whoever's job that is. You know, good luck with that. That seems like that's a hard one. It's crazy that you just mentioned that because in the metamorphosis of the prime intellect, I'm only 40% of the way through it. It literally brings up the Asimov three rules of robotics or laws of robotics or whatever it is. And literally they're talking about that contradiction that,
这不是我的工作，但这是别人的工作。祝那个负责的人好运吧。你知道，祝他好运。这看起来是个难题。你刚才提到这个真是太巧了，因为在《原始智能的蜕变》中，我才读了 40%。它字面上就提到了阿西莫夫的机器人三定律，或者不管叫什么。他们确实在讨论那个矛盾，即，
at one point, you know, there's this sentient, intelligent, whatever, I don't even know what it is, system algorithm. And it's called the prime intellect. And it is told to do something, but it would have harmed or potentially put a human at risk. And so he says, well, I can't do that because of my, the first rule. The first rule overrides the second rule. And then military corporate interests are upset because, you know, they can't harm people. Yeah. All right.
在某个时刻，你知道，有一个有感知、有智能的，不管是什么，系统算法。它被称为“原始智能”（Prime Intellect）。它被要求做某事，但这会伤害或可能使人类处于危险之中。所以它说，好吧，我不能那样做，因为我的第一定律。第一定律凌驾于第二定律之上。然后军事和企业利益相关者就很不高兴，因为他们不能伤害人。是的。好吧。
Well, I should let you get going to your... All right. We're supposed to still, on the docket of topics is parrot. We still have not actually had a full parrot deep dive. But we've not. We've not. I mean, that was one of the last things we mentioned was back in October. We got to have a parrot breakdown.
那我就不耽误你去忙你的……好了。我们本来还应该讨论“鹦鹉”（Parrot）这个话题。我们还没进行过完整的“鹦鹉”深度解析。但我们还没做。我们还没做。我是说，那是我们十月份提到的最后一件事了。我们得对“鹦鹉”进行一次拆解。
But coming in the future, folks. Yeah. Well, we can record. At some point, we can record when you give me an update on parrot. And then people can experience. All right. Till next time, folks. That is the 2026 look-ahead episode.
但未来会有的，各位。是的。好吧，我们可以录制。在某个时候，当你给我关于“鹦鹉”的最新进展时，我们可以录制。然后大家就能体验到了。好了，下次见，各位。这就是 2026 年展望节目。
And we look forward to all of your comments and feedback on the last episode. If you want to leave comments and feedback on this one, there will be another GitHub discussion as well. Until then, be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
我们期待大家对上一集的评论和反馈。如果你想对这一集留下评论和反馈，也会有另一个 GitHub 讨论区。在那之前，请务必查看节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，那里有我们今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论区的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality. high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。